-You were known,
certainly early in your time
on the show,
for Digital Shorts,
but then, also,
so many great live sketches.
Second Chance Theater --
we've done a couple
of your Second Chance Theaters
at this point.
So you would think
we're running out.
-Yeah.
-You did play a male stripper.
-[ Laughs ]
-Tell us a little bit about this
sketch that did not go.
-Yeah.
So, this is a sketch
that I remembered really fondly.
And then,
I dug around and read it.
And...
-[ Laughing ]
It was a sketch I wrote
with Rob Klein,
which is, I believe,
who I've written
every Second Chance Theater
with.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-It was Rosario Dawson
was the host.
And it was
her bachelorette party,
and her friends take her to,
like, a strip club.
And I'm the stripper.
I come popping out of
a giant birthday cake.
And basically,
the sell of the sketch
is that my character
has extremely long nipples.
Like, basically,
when he first pops off his top,
he's like,
"Who's ready for the Slim Jims?"
[ Both laugh ]
And then, a lot of talk about,
like, "I heard someone
has a sweet tooth
for pink taffy,"
and that kind of stuff.
And I did a move called
the car wash, where I was, like,
spinning the long nips
like tassels.
And you know,
I'm sad I never got to try it.
Because just
the prosthetic element alone --
-It did not get to dress, even.
-No, not even close.
Oh.
That's weird.
We picked up our coffees
at the same time.
-Yeah.
-Huh.
-Hmm.
-It's interesting, Seth.
You know,
we're wearing the same shirt,
we're both drinking coffee.
We're basically
on level ground here.
Don't you think?
-Yeah. I guess --
I guess Zoom
has leveled things out.
-Like, without the studio
and your big desk
where you can kind of
lord over people
like the judge of all things,
it's almost like
I'm hosting
just as much as you are.
Wouldn't you say?
-I wouldn't, but I see
where you're coming from.
-Anyhow, now that I've got this
opportunity to host your show,
it's time for you
to get in the hot seat.
♪♪
All right.
Check this out.
I'm the host.
I'm smart.
All right, Seth,
you ready to get
into the hot seat and answer
some hard-hitting questions?
-Mm-hmm.
-Ahh.
-Can we put a graphic --
Can we put a graphic over
the "Seth Meyers"
and put an "Andy Samberg"
right here?
-[ Laughs ]
We're gonna find out if that's
in the budget later.
[ Both laugh ]
It's not like you're spending
a lot on lights.
[ Both laugh ]
It sucks!
It's just for the Internet,
though, so it doesn't matter.
What's that?
It's gonna air on television?
What is going on?!
-[ Laughs ]
-All right, Seth.
Question number one.
-Okay, great.
-You and Alexi
gonna have another baby?
-I don't know.
Maybe.
-Oh.
You're pretty chill about that.
-Yeah.
-All right.
Question number two...
who do you think's the best
"Weekend Update" anchor
of all time?
-Oh.
I mean, gun to my head,
I'd say Norm.
-Oh, wow, yeah.
I think I might agree.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-[Bleep]
-I shouldn't have said that.
You're in the hot seat.
-[ Laughs ]
-This is a bit.
[ Both laugh ]
Okay.
Question number three.
Who do you think Lorne likes
better between Tina and Amy?
-Oh, that's a good question.
I think his happiness
is dependent
on a very careful equilibrium.
And he wants to make sure
that each of them
is desperately trying to, like,
tip ahead of the other.
-That was a good answer.
Honestly, you're being
way more calm
about these questions
than I was expecting.
-[ Laughs ]
-I feel like I'm dumping sweat.
[ Both laugh ]
-You are -- Wait.
Do you think you accidentally --
you are sitting in the hot seat,
by your own making?
-See, this is what
I can't tell with Zoom.
Like, maybe I'm the one
in the hot seat.
-Right.
-Oh, man.
Do you hear that?
My family's really
stomping around up there.
I'm in the basement.
[ Both laugh ]
All right.
Favorite Hamilton --
"Hamilton" the musical
or "Hamilton,"
the Will Forte sketch?
-Oh, "Hamilton Whiteman,"
the Will Forte sketch.
And "Hamilton" the musical's
very good, but, yeah.
"Hamilton" the Forte sketch,
as you know, a man --
a character who gave toasts at
both of our rehearsal dinners.
-True.
It's true.
You know who never did that?
-Who's that?
-Alexander Hamilton.
-[ Laughing ]
That is true.
-Thanks for nothing, dick!
-[ Laughs ]
-All right.
Um...
If you -- If you had to hook up
with one member
of The Lonely Island,
which one would it be?
-[ Laughs ]
"Hook up with"?
-Yeah.
Answer the question!
-Well --
-It's the hot seat.
You have to answer.
-I mean,
don't take this the wrong way,
but I feel like Akiva
would be the least needy.
-Yeah.
Also...
least amount of hair,
which, for me, is a plus.
-Yeah.
-And I think it's close
between me and him,
but smells the best.
-Okay.
That's good to know.
-Like, very hygienic.
-I feel like I chose well.
-Yeah, Jorm has, like, more of
a, like, woodsman's musk.
-Yeah, sort of that Bay Area...
-Yeah.
And, look,
there's an audience for that.
On RedTube.
[ Both laugh ]
Can we shout out RedTube?
Anyways...
-[ Laughs ]
-Does that mean the hot seat's
over, the removal of the pencil?
[ Laughing ]
-Anyway, we're going
in to a new segment.
-No. Wait. There's not time
for a new segment.
[ Both laugh ]
-Hey, it's Mr. Frog!
What's up, dude?!
Hey, Frisbee,
you can suck my [bleep] dude!
Waaaaah!
-What?! I can't believe
I produced a whole show.
Just for this promo.
Watch "Palm Springs," guys.
-Watch "Palm Springs."
-Hello!
Mr. Rabbit here!
Hello!
-It's for the Internet, Seth.
This doesn't matter.
Hello!
-It's on NBC.
-It shouldn't be!
Terrible.
This is not good TV.
♪ Hoo, doo doo doo doo ♪
♪ Jumping butts ♪
♪ There's a pool of sweat
under my butt ♪
-[ Laughs ]
-I'm working on ventriloquism.
-Thank you so much
for being on tonight.
I really --
I think it was really good.